my name is jim schwartz graduate of the
school of industrial administration
which is what the pepper school used to
be named and i have a Master of Science
in industrial administration for my
school I really feel strongly that that
I received a just of incredibly good
first-rate education here part of the
gift was to create more entrepreneurial
courses and campus-wide exposure to
entrepreneurship so it's not just about
building technical companies or startups
or whatever but it's it's about helping
students learn a way of life that's
going to serve them well in the future
because of the basically the campus lay
out here and in the nature of the school
there was a real opportunity to create a
physical environment where many of these
assets could be connected but on a
regular free-flowing basis it's it's not
just the fit the one central physical
center but it's really the whole network
of activities that will be taking place
under this umbrella today the average
age has moved on to 25 28 something
there's a lot of teenagers that are
entrepreneurs these days and that's
required a totally different way of
thinking and that's why it's really
important for colleges and universities
to be really accurately involved in this
process I think someone who is
interested in entrepreneurship just
really needs to experience it and this
and and hang out with like-minded
individuals and see how it feels
you